oh
my God
[Music]
[Applause]
I'm not going to hockey puck out there
my Arrangement is classic we don't have
to do that trash
do you guys miss Lucy's in the front row
she loves everything I do great only fan
is here she doesn't count Melissa listen
up my dad has invested way too much
money into this group for us to bail the
first year of competition we're gonna go
out there and show them what we are all
about some things are best left to
mystery ma'am these fits look like we're
about to unveil the new iPad you
ungrateful
[Music]
you're doing it
we're doing it
[Music]
[Applause]
I'm sorry excuse me brother this is for
the pastors only
Bishop Headley I'm man it is an honor to
meet you of course it is
um James Goodman this is my wife Now
assistant they call me PG I'm a pastor
really
but I know other preachers in this city
with those tattoos
man I tell you uh I didn't ever think I
was going to be a pastor so I put my
whole life story on the outside but
thank God it's Grace able to cover up
some of them chapters you know what I
mean it's Grace
[Applause]
[Music]
oh welcome to the competition children
these outfits are giving so when does
the new iPhone drop move
oh Big Love what are we gonna do Jess
I've been praying all night
God gonna do you can kind of rap right
I'm rap I'll be rapping I'll be rapping
so if it all goes bad and the card turns
on us just go for it I'll back you up
God willing
[Applause]
[Music]
my love
that's the wrong note ciao
so good it made me feel so good what is
he doing man in the church right now
amen amen he made me want to spread love
to the new guy I used to question each
day
oh
[Music]
you know the kind double backer why I
see that booting from behind thank Jesus
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
all the way to Hell bless you
[Music]
stay down stay stay down
baby
[Applause]